okay listen okay shut the up
she said what she said yes absolutely
Nicki Minaj telling the VMA crowd to
shut up as she presents the best
Direction award she also debuted a new
song off her Pink Friday 2 album during
her performance
[Applause]
Mickey pulled double duty as host and
performer knocking out the task for the
second year in a row I'm a bad this is
crazy
MTV is petrified because they got a
couple calls yesterday and and people
were saying what if Nikki says this and
if Nikki says that
and you know and I said it's okay MTV I
can control myself
because if you can't control yourself
you can't control anything around you
right
and as the rapper set the record
straight she stunned as a Barbie bride I
mean it's pretty obvious
then hit the stage as she performed her
newest single last time I saw you for
the very first time
[Applause]
[Music]
I wish I didn't always precious
Nikki who was nominated for six Awards
including artist of the year didn't end
her set without turning up the heat
that's always the goal I always want to
be great at anything I do I don't want
to come in there looking like the rapper
that's trying to act you know well she
definitely gave a show giving fans a
Pink Friday two exclusive sharing a new
Untitled song
[Applause]
she also had a message for the crowd
before she presented Taylor Swift with
the award for best Direction who do you
guys think it is
okay on account okay listen okay shut
the up
I didn't expect myself to be one of
those people who didn't care about the
hoopla but I really don't Nikki ended
the Night by surprising her fans with a
performance of her hit Itty Bitty Piggy
before signing off with this sweet
goodbye Make some noise for yourselves
you guys were so amazing I am asking God
to bless these people tonight because
they are so beautiful and so perfect and
I love you so much MCV I love you I had
a blast I'll see you guys
hi
[Music]